well let's talk to the man who makes
that new banknotes Martin Sutherland is
chief executive of Delarue so Martin how
expensive and time-consuming has it been
to devise all these new security
features well finally it's at the heart
of what dollar II does we're one of the
biggest we are the biggest commercial
producer of banknotes in the world we're
working with over 140 countries helping
design notes and so it's kind of core to
what we do is you know how do we come up
with symbols of national pride you know
capturing iconic people like Jane Austen
the cost really is a secondary issue
isn't it well there's a little grousing
on twitter this afternoon there you go
that quotation on the note I declare
after all there is no enjoyment like
reading
that's a quote not from Jane Austen but
from one of her characters was that your
fault all the banks well we work really
closely with our customers we worked
really closely with the Bank of England
to make sure that as I say we can
capture the spirit of the nation in the
cash so if you look at the new ten pound
note I think it's a fantastic design
it's got all sorts of different security
features in it if you compare the new
tenor with the old tenor it's a sort of
generational shift in terms of the look
and the feel it's on this new polymer it
makes it much more difficult to
counterfeit so I think all those things
that you know fantastic positives the
fact that the public engage so
passionately with what's the quote on
the note or is the image the right image
is it the right you know portrait I
think it says something about how
important cash is to the general the
general public but the bank signed off
on the quotes that's not that's not us
but we work closely with customers so
yeah it's the bank that you know chose
the the portrait of Jane Austen and then
it's our design team very skilled at you
know artists who turn that into an
engraving that goes on the note and we
work with a bank and they chose the
quote now and we had a lot of grouting
when the new fiber was launched which
was one of yours as well about the use
of tallow in the notes why is that
essential so the actually the polymer
that the five and the ten pound note is
printed on is not he's not dollar a
polymer it's provided by another company
right okay we do make polymer in impact
notes and we since the the sort of
public reaction to the tallow in the
five-pound note we've put our research
team to work and we've actually now
brought out
sort of alternative variant which
doesn't have the tallow in the note so
as far as we're concerned at the LaRue
we can do a tallow free or at a low
version of a note and we're actually
competing to supply the polymer for the
20 pound note at the moment with the
Bank of England so hopefully we'll we'll
be successful in that tender how
interesting now another thing you're
competing on your you're currently the
passport supplier your re tendering for
the business is that harder this time
around because of the imminence of the
UK leaving the EU gonna have a whole new
design well whether or not there's a new
design of the passport again that's that
we're down to the UK passport service
what I would note is that we've been
working closely with the passport
service for the last ten years so dollar
who produces the British passport today
again I think it's a fantastic symbol of
sort of national pride if you open up
the passport it's got you know pictures
of the Globe Theatre and you know the
Tube map and so on so it really sort of
you know captures the spirit of the
nation the contract ends in 2019 that's
the year that we will be leaving Europe
if the brexit negotiations go to plan so
I think actually be very disappointing
if it wasn't a British company that was
producing the new British passport yeah
so hopefully we'll continue to enjoy
that relationship alright in a word do
you think they'll be blue I think it'd
be quite exciting if anywhere wouldn't
it yeah great stuff Martin sovereign
from delery good to see you thanks for
joining